laut nasa chef jim brittens sein ist es
die bedeutendste entwicklung die für das
leben außerhalb der erde spricht die
spektakuläre entdeckung des gases mono
fonds fahnen der venus atmosphäre
versetzt forschungsteams weltweit in
aufregung und auch der us
raumfahrtbehörde nasa lässt dieser fund
keine ruhe denn diese verbindung wird
nur von mikroorganismen produziert
zumindest ist das auf der erde so der
fall
und jetzt soll möglichst bald raumfahrt
missionen zur venus aufbrechen um diese
mikroorganismen zu finden klicks umsatz
im future bis dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's hat sie
willkommen pixum gibt es übrigens auch
als podcast nur für eure ohren die links
dazu sind hier unter oder in der video
beschreibung hier unten
ja so kann es gehen gerade noch stürzen
sich alle auf den mars um das erste
außerirdische leben zu finden und jetzt
ist es plötzlich die venus die im visier
der us raumfahrtbehörde nasa steht seit
dem gas fund auf der venus ist dieser
planet in den fokus der forschung
gerutscht ein eher seltenes und vor
allem auch giftiges gas hält die
fachwelt in atem
die rede ist vom ohne phosphat einem
molekül das aus drei atom wasserstoff
und einem atom phosphor besteht das
besondere daran dieses gas kommt auf der
erde nur als stoffwechselprodukt winzige
bakterien vor beispielsweise wird es von
mikroorganismen produziert die im kot
von pinguinen existieren
auf der erde wird diese substanz
außerdem auch von menschen künstlich
hergestellt um damit schädlinge zu
bekämpfen jetzt aber im september 2020
wurde das super spannende ergebnis eines
walisischen forschungsteams
veröffentlicht demnach haben die
fachleute um die astronomen jane greaves
mit hilfe von radioteleskopen in chile
und hawaii in der venus atmosphäre einen
super spektakulären fund gemacht denn
dort konnten sie mono fonds fahren
nachweisen wie sie im fachmagazin nature
astronomie schreiben wir hatten darüber
hierbei krieg substanzen future
ausführlich berichtet kurz zur erklärung
das phosphor atom in dieser verbindung
ist extrem reaktiv und genau das ist der
grund dafür warum dieses molekül
normalerweise schnell wieder
verschwindet warum also
befindet es sich in der atmosphäre der
venus und wie kommt es vor allem dorthin
astronomen und astronom weltweit lässt
das nicht mehr ruhig schlafen denn bis
dann können wir keinen biologischen oder
chemischen mechanismus bei dem die
verbindung auf der venus immer wieder
neu entstehen würde bedeutet das etwa
dass in einer höhe von 50 bis 70
kilometern über der venus oberfläche
mikroorganismen existieren und für
diesen stoff verantwortlich sind
möglicherweise handelt es sich um
lebensform die sehr an bärtierchen
erinnern diese könnten sich in den
verschiedenen schichten der atmosphäre
hin und herbewegen in den unteren sehr
heißen schichten würde diese spezies
dehydrieren und in eine art starre
verfallen
in den oberen schichten dagegen könnte
sie dann wieder erwachen die planeten
wissenschaftlerin sarah sieger vom
massachusetts institute of technology
hält diese version oder diese
möglichkeit des lebens in den oberen
schichten der venus ja für möglich dirk
schulze makuch ist professor für
astrobiologie an der tu berlin und
mitautor des buchs kos mit biologie und
bestätigt diese these
trotz der lebensfeindlichen bedingungen
in der venus atmosphäre auf der anderen
seite hat uns neben schon mehrmals
überrascht das war dort wo wir nicht
dachten dass es möglich wäre zum
beispiel direkt am kochend heißen
quellen am meeresboden und in der
trockensten wüste der welt der
atacama-wüste trotz all dieser
spekulation der forschenden in der
aktuellen studie wird der fund des
monats aus fans jedenfalls ausdrücklich
nicht als beweis für leben auf der venus
interpretiert sondern nur für zitat
anormale und unerklärliche chemie wie
das autorenteam schreibt ein beweis kann
es auch nicht sein weil es halt immer
noch irgendwelche anderen möglichkeiten
geben könnte ein beweis wer nur wenn man
wirklich diese mikroorganismen dann auch
finden würde
ja aber es ist eben ein indiz und ein
sehr vielversprechendes denn vulkane
meteoriten blitze oder sonnenlicht
können nicht die erklärung für die
beständige neubildung dieser verbindung
seien vor allem in der menge die dort in
der atmosphäre vorherrscht dafür sei die
gesamtmenge der substanz in der venus
atmosphäre einfach viel zu groß an den
riesigen gas planeten saturn jupiter
wurde in der vergangenheit
übrigens auch schon mono fonds fahren
nachgewiesen doch hier sind die
gigantischen energiemengen im inneren
dieser himmelskörper die erklärung dafür
bei der venus ist das aber nicht der
fall ausgeschlossen ist es somit also
noch lange nicht dass wir es mit dieser
entdeckung endlich geschafft haben
außerirdischen leben auf die schliche
gekommen zu sein im gegenteil trotz der
vielen zweifel bleibt leben im moment
rein wissenschaftlich gesehen die
einzige erklärung und wie apple
professor für astronomie in harvard und
leiter der astronomischen abteilung dort
hier bei uns bei pixum future so schön
sherlock holmes zitierte wenn man das
unmögliche ausgeschlossen hat muss das
was übrig bleibt die wahrheit sein so
unwahrscheinlich sie auch klingen mag
und die nasa scheint genau das ins auge
gefasst zu haben ihr chef jim brittens
sein schrieb am 14 september 2020 auf
twitter leben auf der venus die
entdeckung von mono fonds von einem
nebenprodukt der neurobiologie ist die
bisher bedeutendste entwicklung die für
das leben außerhalb der erde spricht vor
etwa zehn jahren entdeckte die nasa
mikrobiellen leben in 120 tausend fuß
höhe in der oberen atmosphäre der erde
es ist an der zeit der venus priorität
einzuräumen und das soll jetzt auch
passieren jetzt soll es ganz schnell zur
venus gehen und die nasa hat bereits mit
der planung begonnen an gremium der us
raumfahrtbehörde wiegt jetzt ab welche
der möglichen venus mission zeitnah
starten könnten
und dabei vor allem auch
erfolgversprechende forschung
ermöglichen könnte
ganz vorne mit dabei ist das so genannte
da vinci plus programm der nasa hier
könnte sich eine roboter sondern auf den
weg zur venus machen und dort die
atmosphäre des planeten untersuchen
denn genau dieser dichte gas mantel der
venus ist für die forschung besonders
spannend denn klar die jüngsten
studienergebnisse könnten hinweise
darauf sein dass hier eben
mikroorganismen existieren die die gas
verbindung aus einem fonds für atom und
drei wasserstoffatom produzieren dazu
der nasa forscher david greene spoon
wenn man den ergebnissen der studien
nachgehen will dann ist da vinci die
logische wahl denn man muss einfach
dorthin reisen und sehen was in der
atmosphäre vor sich geht da vinci steht
für die pet muss für wen ist
investigation of nobel gastes chemistry
and imaging bereits vor fünf jahren
wurde dieses
konzept der nasa vorgeschlagen im
februar diesen jahres 2020 hatte ich das
nasa gremium es dann mit in die engere
wahl aufgenommen konkret könnte sich die
da vinci sonde durch die atmosphäre der
venus bewegung dabei verschiedene
messungen vornehmen
wie ist die atmosphäre zusammengesetzt
wie ist sie entstanden und welche
chemischen prozesse laufen dort ab und
warum
neben den messungen könnte die roboter
sande aber auch bilder von der
planetenoberfläche liefern denn klar ist
so unklar wie die venus derzeit scheint
war sie wohl in der vergangenheit nicht
die venus kann man sich vorstellen wie
eine echte höllen landschaft hier
herrscht eine durchschnittstemperatur
von rund 460 grad celsius sodass das
heißt genug wäre um blei zu schmelzen
die atmosphäre des planeten besteht zum
größten teil aus kohlendioxid und ist
zudem extrem dicht so herrscht auf der
venus an druck der auf der erde rund 900
meter unter wasser zu finden ist doch in
der vergangenheit sah die venus
offensichtlich ganz anders aus bedeckt
mit ozean und somit vielleicht sogar
bewohnbar
das ist wirklich eine kuriose
vorstellung die venus mit einer deutlich
kühleren oberfläche als heute und zudem
noch bedeckt von zahlreichen ozean ein
planet also auf dem leben eines sehr gut
vorstellbar wäre demnach könnte der
planet tatsächlich eine ganze zeit lang
äusserst lebensfreundliche
umweltbedingungen geboten haben - soll
in diesem stadium sogar der erde
ziemlich ähnlich gewesen sein
mithilfe von simulationen an einem
numerischen gezeigten modell kommen
forschende erst vor kurzem zu diesem
spannenden ergebnis demnach könnten die
ozeane der venus damals wie eine art
bremse auf die rotationsgeschwindigkeit
des planeten eingewirkt haben die
vorhandenen ozeane haben also dafür
gesorgt dass sich die drehung der venus
deutlich verlangsamt hat vereinfacht
gesagt ist dies auf die reibung
zurückzuführen die bei flut und ebbe
zwischen einem ozean und dem meeresboden
wirkt auch diese studie aus dem
vergangenen jahr 2009 10 hatte bereits
deutlich gemacht dass die venus bei der
suche nach außerirdischem leben eine
bedeutende rolle spielen könnte als die
forschung bislang gedacht hatte
denn falls die venus mit großen
lebensfreundlichen ozean vielleicht
sogar drei milliarden jahre lang
tatsächlich wie die erde aus gesehen hat
ist auch eine sache ganz klar die
evolution hatte hier genug zeit
leben zu erschaffen und vielleicht haben
besonders hartnäckige organismen eben
sogar bis heute überleben können dazu
der us astronom dhabi ja warum
investieren wir so viel zeit in die
suche nach leben auf dem mars wenn es
dort noch 400 millionen jahre lang
flüssiges wasser gab
und dann steht dagegen die venus mit
drei milliarden jahren wasser und
niemand interessiert sich für sie nicht
auszuschließen also dass die venus sogar
der erste bewohnbare planet im
sonnensystem war dazu der pariser
astronom thomas wiedemann
das alles könnte der beginn eines neuen
jahrzehnts der venus sein
das nasa gremium denkt außerdem auch
über eine weitere mögliche venus mission
nach ihr name veritas das steht für wien
sms city radio science insa topographie
und spektroskopie auch hier würde eine
sonde zum einsatz kommen die im
gegensatz zur da vinci sonder aber eher
die geologischen eigenschaften der venus
und deren oberfläche ins visier nehmen
würde
dieses programm könnte eine laufzeit von
drei jahren und auch hier könnten uns
rada bilddaten und nah infrarot
spektrografen spannende erkenntnisse
liefern im visier der veritas mission
stünde auch der vulkanismus auf der
venus denn hier ist der so genannte hot
spot vulkanismus zu finden also gebiete
mit einer aktiven großen unterirdischen
magma kammer 2015 fand ein
forschungsteam der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa überzeugende
hinweise darauf dass die venus auch
heute noch vulkanisch aktiv ist eine
heiße und dichte wolken schicht hatte
das bis dahin im verborgenen gehalten
doch der infrarotdetektoren der esa
raumsonde venus express konnte mehrere
hotspots aufspüren die eine auffallend
erhöhte temperatur aufweisen und zwar
bereits bekannten vulkan regionen auf
der venus die vermutung der forschenden
frische aber bereits erstarrte
lavaströme außerdem konnten schwankendes
schwefeldioxid werte in der atmosphäre
entdeckt werden auch das lässt auf
aktiven vulkanismus schließen dazu hans
wtm einer der beteiligten esa forscher
unsere studie zeigt dass die venus unser
nächster nachbar noch heute aktiv ist
und sich verändert das ist
wichtiger schritt auf unsere erforschung
der geschichte dieses und unseres
planeten allerdings werden hier offene
lavaflüsse vermutet und keine ausbrüche
wie bei uns auf der erde dilaver soll
demnach leicht und flüssig aus der venus
oberfläche heraustreten und dann wieder
unter die küste zurück strömen bis zu
mehreren hundert kilometern könnten die
lavaströme lang sein das interesse der
nasa an der venus jedenfalls ist jetzt
riesig und so ist es auch nicht
auszuschließen dass die
us-raumfahrtbehörde möglicherweise sogar
bei den missionen an den start bringt im
april des kommenden jahres 2021 will die
nasa diese wichtige und wohl auch
schwierige entscheidungen treffen die
beiden missionen beschreibt der nasa
chef jim breitenstein in einer
offiziellen pressemitteilung der
us-raumfahrtbehörde folgendermaßen eine
konzentriert sich auf das verständnis
der venus atmosphäre und die andere
mission auf das verständnis der
geologischen geschichte der venus es
besteht kein zweifel dass es den
verantwortlichen der nasa schwer fahren
wird diese sehr überzeugenden ziele und
missionen zu bewerten und auszuwählen
doch bin ich ganz sicher dass der
prozess fair und unvoreingenommen sein
wird die usa arbeiten auch mit europa
bei einer weiteren geplanten venus
mission namens entwischen zusammen auch
hier soll im kommenden jahr 2021 eine
grundsatzentscheidung getroffen werden
nasa chef jim bundestag fordert
nachdrücklich die venus jetzt als einen
neuen globalen forschungsschwerpunkt zu
begreifen das ist ja auch kein wunder
denn leben auf der venus wissenschaft
findet für sensationsfund nur eine
erklärung anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar diesen kanal pixum
science fiction bis dann bleibt dran